-I am and have always been
a normal homosexual man
who does all the normal things
normal homosexual men do.
-Like what?
-Well, I'll tell you.
♪ I wake up, drink my coffee ♪
♪ Have brunch around 11 ♪
♪ Walk my Bichon-Frisé,
then nap till half past seven ♪
♪ A night out at the symphony ♪
♪ Such elegance, what poise? ♪
♪ Or maybe I'll just stay at
home with my two Sewer Boys ♪
-What?
-♪ The answer
is perfectly clear ♪
♪ It's a gay old life
being queer ♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Nathan Lane.
That was a clip
from "Dicks: The Musical."
-Yes.
-And this is a story
about separated twins.
-Yes. It's a --
it is a deeply silly,
satirical, absurdist,
R-rated queer musical
based on "The Parent Trap."
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
-And, you know,
it's not for everybody.
It's for -- It's for the gay
and the --
and the open minded.
It's for the demented
and depraved.
[ Laughter ]
It is the cinematic enema
America has been
so desperate for.
So, you know, I would say have
an edible or two and run,
don't walk to catch
some "Dicks: The Musical."
-[ Laughs ] Now, in the clip,
you referenced the Sewer Boys,
and I'm glad you brought them
because we don't see them
in the clip.
-I know
-And I -- they really,
no offense,
they kind of steal the show.
-Oh, totally.
And it's all anyone's
talking about
aside from Taylor Swift,
the Sewer Boys.
-So, do you want to set up
the Sewer Boys?
-The Sewer Boys are -- are --
are these creatures
I captured, obviously
in the sewer,
and I take them into my home
and they're like rescue dogs
and I keep them in a cage
in my living room.
[ Clears throat ] And I feed
them sort of like a mother bird.
They like deli meat,
so I chew up ham
and I spit it into their mouths.
You know, like their mother.
-When doing that is
an award-winning actor...
-Yes.
-...what's going
through your head?
-Well, you know, when -- when we
talked about this,
at first when
they brought them out,
most of the budget went into
these puppets, by the way.
And when they brought them out,
I said, this looks like someone
stole a Halloween display
from Walmart.
This can't possibly
be the real thing.
And they said,
"Oh, no, don't worry,
we're just getting started."
And then they put
diapers on them.
[ Laughter ]
So these are my --
my Sewer Boys.
-Alright.
There's...
-And -- and as you can see,
they -- they -- they --
they wear diapers.
In the sewer,
they didn't have to.
-I want to tell you,
it's a wonderful thing.
First of all, there's so much
heavier than they look.
-Right? Me too.
-And...
-Oh, they -- they wear
ankle bracelets as well.
-And their -- their names.
I think this is the litmus test.
They're disgusting,
aren't they?
I think the litmus test
for this movie
are the names of the Sewer Boys
are Backpack and whisper.
[ Laughter ]
-Now -- now, if you think
that's funny,
this is the movie for you.
And and if not, then you should
probably stay home
and watch that marathon
of "Blue Bloods."
-Yes.
Now, I do want
to say one thing before.
You were very nice and said
let's bring the Sewer Boys
on the show.
-Yeah.
-And we had to send --
because they're very heavy.
We couldn't ask you
to bring them,
so we spent a production
assistant.
-They don't really live with me.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Yeah.
They were --
they were at age A24.
-Yeah. So we sent a production
assistant to get them.
-Yeah. And what happened?
-And she brought them
on the subway like this?
-No.
-And guess what?
No one batted an eye.
[ Laughter ]
New York City, baby.
Nathan Lane, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dicks: The Musical"
opens nationwide this Friday,
and the soundtrack
is available now.
We'll be right back
with Lauren Schuker Blum
and Rebecca Angelo.